One of the things we keep asking our startups to think about is
how big is this opportunity?
That's just a fancy word for saying when you're all done
and you're spending the next couple years in the startup
are you going to make a million, or are you going to make a billion?
That is, how potentially large is the opportunity?
And so what we really want to do is do what we call
a market and opportunity analysis.
What you've already put together is a business model canvas
with your hypothesis that says, "Look, we're really passionate about
this product or service, and we think there's a set of customers out there,
and we've put together a revenue model, our first hypotheses
and saying we're going to make a lot of money," and that's great,
but there's really kind of a method to this madness,
and there's not only one way to do this,
but this is the way we kind of think of it.
You want to identify who your customers and markets are,
and you have, but you now want to size the market,
look at competitors, and figure out whether this market could grow.